all right everyone calm down calm down
hello everyone it's only me dr. alto
clef at your service
yes researcher Miller couldn't make it
today so I'm gonna take his little class
well what are we looking at today uh a
cp8 82 object class Euclid special
containment procedures SCP 882 is to be
kept in a fluid environment at all times
consisting of no less than 40% seawater
object is to be kept suspended by
nonmetallic means currently cotton fiber
line that is to be changed daily object
is also to be checked daily for any
signs of rust flaking if any part of
scp-821 coated with rust it must
immediately be immersed in a 100%
seawater solution water must be taken
directly from the ocean reduce
concentration only when the object is
again coated in rust no metal may be
placed in containment area only organic
materials are allowed and any contact
with SCP 882 requires the use of thick
cotton gloves any metal making contact
with it is to be heat severed melted
down and kept immersed in a hundred
percent sea water in a separate area any
auditory issues reported by the staff
must be reported immediately and
affected personnel must submit a full
psychological examination and depending
on the results either transferred to
another facility or permanent
containment
okay let's get on to the description
that's the real meat and potatoes right
so description SCP 882 appears to be a
random assembly of gears cables pulleys
screws and belts all made of an amalgam
of various metals object size at time of
recovery was approximately 87 cubic
meters current size is approximately 12
cubic meters SCP 882 rusts quickly in
seawater at no identifiable energy
source has been found but all components
will begin to move if not coated and
rust SCP 882 was completely silent at
all times no matter what level of
activity SCP 882 reaches any metal
touching the object will become
permanently affixed to it and over a
period of a few days becomes a new part
of the object organic matter remains
unaffected SCP 882 is extremely
resilient with tensile strength and
toughness above those of aircraft-grade
titanium alloy by weight even though its
composition appears to be of a random
alloy of iron tin gold and other metals
some as of yet unidentified extreme
focused heat must be applied over
several hours to cut even a small
portion free from the main assembly
persons remaining in the vicinity of the
object for prolonged periods have
developed auditory hallucinations while
near the object mainly the sound of
grinding and clicking
the sound intensifies and is abated only
by throwing metal into the object
subjects and advanced states of
psychosis have thrown themselves into
the object resulting in an almost death
by crushing the body is often drawn in
and impossible to recover SCP 882 is
recovered from a location at the
northeast coast of Banks Island area was
barren of all metal and metallic ore in
a one-mile radius SCP 882 was found at
the geometric centre of the area SCP 882
have become submerged in seawater at the
time of discovery a small town was found
nearby abandoned for several years SCP
882 was removed and shortly started to
flake off rust causing the varied parts
to begin to motion after several
accidents dr gears authorised SCP 25:19
to be played on loop which successfully
reduced the objects motion enabling safe
access as CP 882 was then cut down and
contained on site I only got a note here
at the bottom SCP 882 is not to be
brought into the vicinity of SCP 271 or
any object possibly contaminated by
scp-217 addendum this is interview 882 -
one and
play please Nicholas II state your name
for the record please
Richard Loken right everyone call me
Richard
excellent Thank You mr. right do you
recall the date when you first saw the
objective question Oh God when when was
it sure it was a while ago Alan found it
first
like this boat darling he told a few of
the other fellows about it
said they could sell it for a bundle of
scrap we all thought it was a chunk of a
Jetta cargo ship okay at what point did
the device start operating Oh
the next day damn thing shot off Roslin
don't with fleece started spinning slow
then sped up but the time I saw it it
was really running Jenny tried to get it
closer tried to see what was powering a
wireless said quiet but he said got a
bad cut before his I got the hell out of
there haven't seen Clendon off kept
asking us if we were hearing anything
this Parker thought part of it was gold
even tried to jam part of it with a pike
to get at it pie to start fast its
manager a good one when the gear was all
spun around after that most people kept
away were there any other incidents of
people being injured or hearing noises
not at first
that's the thing it was so damn quiet
everyone kind of forgot about it for a
while
almost keeping it in an old soul room at
the doll really went out of their much
he started looking bad said he couldn't
sleep
then grind away for the past started
dropping by tried to talk to him to Todd
to get rid of it he was gone for a
couple of days and suddenly the two of
them turn up together happy as clams mr.
right fine
sorry so father Pat I know that Alan's
younger fresh is day six
say they've got the thing figured out I
wasn't paying that much attention this
whole thing had me spooked hearing star
from story grinding squealing really
quiet anyway there said some damn thing
about it being from somewhere else that
God made it that was it to me and I left
did you believe them what that it was
from God no no I don't know I didn't
really know what to think that machine
kept spinning away and power to it an
eating battle to pol mrs. Parker hit it
with it turned into a giant screw shaft
the bucket had always been there more
people started getting interested
started listening to Helen and father
Pat told everyone to bring metal to him
told them the gears were the voice of
God that grew louder as we turned away
and softer as we brought it offerings
did you bring metal to it as well or
spend any extended period of time near
the object what the hell does that
matter you could hear this thing all
over town got to meet the folks couldn't
even sleep
just clanking grinding screaming at all
hours of the night giving it metal
helped
damn I didn't want to I know it wasn't
God I never said it was everyone else
was falling over themselves to make them
father sir I will request that you calm
yourself I'm asking questions not
accused please return to your seat I'm
sorry I'm sorry over a couple of weeks
everything got mantling it was just how
things were we were pretty isolated you
know it's not like we had much else you
just make a couple of trips out to the
store house tops any metal you have to
find it always seemed to be there just
watching tore a hole in the roof after a
while father Pat started getting strange
telling us it wasn't enough I think the
noise was getting to him
said it needed something more mr. right
I came in one night because I heard
people shouting from the storehouse
father Pat was leading a prayer to this
thing but it didn't sound like any
prayer I knew people coming up and he
bent over them they screamed and then he
turned to that big massive man I thought
he was giving communion until I saw the
playas his hat I'm sorry pliers he was
yelling out people's feelings not being
enough needed more but there wasn't any
more left anywhere then he pointed out
and he said he was hiding people from
the great machine and then screamed he
didn't have anything father Pat father
Pat said he joined everyone
Oh God they grabbed him everyone just go
to dinner he started screaming he kept
screaming and scream and nobody cared so
it's all going so so pull the rest of
the army and I ran what can I do it were
too many and that thing screaming and
screaming
this interview is concluded Thank You
mr. right security please see mr. Ryder
[Music]
um closing statement mr. right attempted
suicide shortly after interview subject
is currently being held on suicide watch
and for observation all right calm down
I know kind of upsetting right
nobody said your time with the
foundation was gonna be picnics and hugs
and cotton candy parties so let's just
leave it there okay everybody just go go
away Wow and I really got a VTOL these
tapes before I play them
you